MY GUEST TONIGHT, UNITED STATES
SNARKTS REPRESENTING THE GREAT
STATE OF KENTUCKY!
HIS NEW BOOK, MOVING BEYOND
PARTISAN POLITICS TO UNITE
AMERICA.
THAT'S LIKELY
(LAUGHTER)
PLEASE WELCOME BACK TO THE
PROGRAM, SENATOR RAND PAUL!
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
HAVE SOME WATER, I KNOW YOU MUST
BE TIRED.
WHAT WAS THAT, 11 HOURS OF
FILIBUSTERING.
YOU GOTTA BE EXHAUSTED.
CAN I ASK YOU A QUESTION?
CAN YOU GO TO THE BATHROOM?
DO YOU GET 30 SECONDS, CAN YOU
GO?
>> NO, YOU HAVE TO STAND THE
WHOLE TIME.
YOU CANNOT SIT DOWN OR LEAVE THE
FLOOR.
>> Jon: CAN YOU HAVE A
SUBSTITUTE COME IN FOR JUST
A MINUTE?
>> NO.
NOW, THERE  A STORY OF STROM
THURMAN ONCE UPON A TIME GOING
TO THE CLOAK ROOM DOOR AND
RELIEVING HIMSELF INTO A WASTE
BUCKET.
>> Jon: THERE ARE A LOT OF
STORIES ABOUT STROM THURMAN.
THAT MIGHT BE THE NICEST ONE.
>> BUT THE THING IS THAT WAS
BEFORE TV -- AND I DIDN'T WANT
TO IMPRESS THEM, YOU KNOW, WITH
THE EOMITION THING.
>> Jon: YEAH, I GET THAT.
RESPECT.
THIS IDEA, BY THE WAY, YOU KNOW,
YOUR PARTY IS KNOWN FOR WANTING
TO DEFEND THE PEOPLE OF AMERICA
FROM GOVERNMENT OVERREACH,
TO PROTECT LIBERTY, I BELIEVE
THEY CALL IT, THEY HAVE SIGNS --
(LAUGHTER)
-- "DON'T TREAD ON ME" FLAGS.
BUT WHEN IT COMES TO GOVERNMENT
SURVEILLANCE, WHEN IS COMES TO
THE SECURITY STATE, THEY SEEM
VERY WILLING TO ALLOW THE
GOVERNMENT, WITH WHAT APPEARS TO
BE VERY LITTLE OVERSIGHT, TO GET
WHATEVER THEY WANT.
>> YOU DIDN'T SEE THE OTHER SIGN
THEY HAVE?
WE DON'T LIKE BIG GOVERNMENT
UNTIL WE DO LIKE BIG GOVERNMENT.
>> Jon: RIGHT, BUT THAT'S MY
POINT.
>> YEAH, THERE IS AN
INCONSISTENCY THERE AND I THINK
THAT'S WHAT SEPARATES SOME OF US
WHO ARE MORE FROM THE
LIBERTARIAN WING OF THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
WE DON'T LIKE BIG GOVERNMENT
ANYWHERE.
>> Jon: NOW, IS THAT -- WHEN
YOU TALKING LIKE THAT, IS THAT
WHY LINDSEY GRAHAM ROLLS HIS
EYES, OR WERE YOU WEARING
WHITE BEFORE MEMORIAL DAY?
(LAUGHTER)
WHAT WAS IT THAT CAUSED HIM --
AND WAS IN UNCOMFORTABLE --
DID THEY TAUNT YOU ABOUT
THAT?
DO THEY THINK, RAND, WHAT ARE
YOU DOING?
WHAT, WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
>> IT WAS MOSTLY, I THINK,
PEOPLE ARE UNHAPPY ABOUT
DEBATING THE BILL OF RIGHTS WHEN
THEY COULD HAVE BEEN ON
MEMORIAL WEEKEND, AND I THINK
IT SHOULD BE THE OPPOSITE.
>> Jon: IN TERMS OF
GOVERNEMTN SURVEILLANCE, LET'S
LOOK AT WHERE THE MAJORITY ARE
AT --
THERE HAVE BEEN MORE SCHOOL
SHOOTINGS, WOULDN'T YOU AGREE,
THAN TERRORISM IN AMERICA OVER
THE LAST 15 YEARS.
>> IT'S VERY EMOTIONAL, THOUGH,
I DON'T WANT TO DISCOUNT
TERRORISM.
>> Jon: WE'RE NOT DISCOUNTING IT
BUT WE HAVE TO LOOK AT IT
REALISTICALLY.
>> THAT'S THE THING, RIGHT NOW
THEY'RE USING SCARE TACTICS
AGAINST ME.
THEY WANT ME TO BACK DOWN
BECAUSE IF  ANYTHING HAPPENS, IF
ANYONE DIES FOR ANY REASON IN
THE WHOLE WORLD, I'M NOW
RESPONSIBLE FOR IT.
14 PEOPLE DIED LAST NIGHT FROM
MURDER IN BALTIMORE.
IS THE POLICE CHIEF RESPONSIBLE
FOR THAT?
MAYBE THE PEOPLE WHO DO THE
KILLING ARE RESPONSIBLE AND THE
REST OF US NEED TO PROTECT
SECURITY BUT ALSO NEED TO
REALIZE WHAT WE'RE FIGHTING
AGAINST.
IF WE'RE FIGHTING THIS WAR
AGAINST TERRORISM WE'RE FIGHTING
TO DEFEND OUR FREEDOMS.
IF WE GIVE UP WHO WE ARE IN THE
ROCESS, I'M WORRIED WILL THE
BATTLE HAVE BEEN WORTH IT.
THE PROBLEM NOW IS WE ARE IN A
WAR THEY SAY IS PERPETUAL.
THEY SAY THE BATTLEGROUND IS
EVERYWHERE AND IT WILL GO ON
FOREVER, THOUSANDS OF YEARS.
AND SO WHEN ARE WE GETTING OUR
FREEDOMS BACK.
BUT I KNOW YOUNG MEN WHO HAVE
LOST TWO LEGS, YOU KNOW, LOST
THREE LIMBS, AND I ASK THEM WHAT
THEY FOUGHT FOR AND THEY SAID
THEY WERE FIGHTING FOR  BILL OF
RIGHTS, SO I THINK IT'S A
DISSERVICE TO THEIR MEMORY FOR
ME TO SAY, OH, WELL, I'M GOING
TO JUST ROLL MY EYES AND THE
BILL OF RIGHTS IS OUT THE WINDOW
BECAUSE I'M NOT WILLING TO STAY
HERE ON THE WEEKEND AND FIGHT
FOR SOMETHING OUR FOUNDING
FATHERS THOUGHT WAS
PRETTY IMPORTANT -- IMPORTANT TO
PUT INTO THE FOURTH AMENDMENT.
>> Jon: I'M GLAD YOU DIDN'T
FRAME THAT IN AN INFLAMMATORY
WAY.
(LAUGHTER)
I'M THE KIND OF GUY WHO DOESN'T
MIND WORKING A WEEKEND IF IT
MEANS OUR SOLDIERS DIDN'T DIE
IN VAIN.
(APPLAUSE)
00:04:02,042 --> 00:00:00,000
I GUESS LINDSEY GRAHAM'S A
DIFFERENT KIND OF GUY.